here in the Clock Tower so another
recognizable location but this is where
crossed wands which is the secret not so
secret dueling Club is that the students
have put together professors definitely
know about it but they think they're
being clever and it's run by this Luke
and bradleby here who's in a younger
year but we kind of like that this that
he's running things
hello Lucan may I use the training dummy
of course I'll fetch it and give you a
list of combinations to practice if I
need to have a try now
foreign
be sure to cast all your
for the dummy lands
this is a really good opportunity to now
jump into combat because really in the
game this is going to be uh the first
time where you yourself get to learn
about combat and combos in a big way and
in a new way for me personally this was
where the game like really starts to
open up to the possibilities uh
so we've set up uh We've set up a
training dummy and this is kind of an
activity where you're supposed to
execute according to kind of the
iconography on the top now what we see
on the top is the accio spell followed
by for what we just kind of lovingly
refer to as basic shots there are
certain spells with the Wizards kind of
like use just kind of fling Andrew's
using one now
and you trigger that by tapping R2 on
your controller so you can see in the
corner R2 so if you tap R2 that throws
out a basic shot but that R2 is also
your gateway to all of the the uh spells
that you might slot so if you hold R2
instead you can see how the diamond
expands and if we let go you see how it
contracts yeah and so if you hold it
again it expands and so when it expands
and all the spells that you slotted
while you're holding that button can now
be tapped with your face buttons awesome
and not only that but over the course of
the game you can gain
um additional spell diamonds up to four
additional ones so that you can slot up
to 16 spells you know pretty much
instantly and then that helped us
um fulfill the fantasy of in combat I
need to be able to access things very
rapidly yeah and and so you learn over
the course of these events you know how
to juggle not just the spell casting but
also it reinforces an understanding of
another feature of the wheel which is
their cooldowns so as you're casting
spells just to make sure that you're not
just kind of like repeatedly using one
thing over and over again you can see
cooldowns on the spells that he's using
uh on the wheel and then as you progress
through the game there are different
things that can affect things like
cooldowns through your talents uh
different things that allow you to kind
of like juggle and adjust and update
those things and so if you hold down our
R2 and you tap the d-pad it will switch
between your other diamonds if you've
unlocked them and and that's how you
access all this oh man
it looks like you're about to get some
action over here
yeah so this is this is a great way to
kind of learn how to
pull things together
um
together yeah
Pacquiao tap tap tap awesome
and that's just against the dummy but I
mean uh uh
I'd say that there thank you Lucan I say
better to discover one's weaknesses
during practice than during a duel
you'll be a fearsome Challenger now
I think now we can uh we can take on
something a little more challenging it's
going to shoot back uh now let's talk
about uh some more features of the
combat system
hello Lucan is the next round of cross
ones all said why yes it is I've
just lined up
we're on a PS5 dev kit here so we're
going to be able to kind of pause the
pause the action and talk about what
you're seeing on the screen because
there's about to be a lot going on okay
okay um
[Music]
all right here you can select if you
want to fight with somebody else some of
your questions yeah but in this case
we're not we want we want that action to
feel a little more frantic towards you
to really get you that sense of of uh of
combat
so apparently you've uh got quite the
reputation because they've got you up
against 53 yeah off the Jump
yeah
um so I can I can explain this uh just
because I know people are going to go
into it but we can probably just kind of
jump in
um so uh you're not the only one that
has protagon the ability to deflect the
enemies do too and we actually play with
that when it comes to the spell casting
so you'll notice that there are
different colored kind of shields around
the different characters and you also
notice that your spells have different
colors on them so to help players
understand kind of like the function of
their spells we're trying to put them
into brackets so there are damage spells
there are four spells there are freaking
in the other one all the control spells
and so those things for the player yeah
they wind up also being a color
indicator for which which actual spell
to use to break the different Shields
that uh enemies can use that way it
rewards kind of like that close
attention that you're paying paying on
things we've got this paused here now
and you can kind of see all the elements
on the screen the the halo around the
Avatar's head each of the different
shields uh to kind of give us give us a
breakdown let's break down different
things that you're saying
um so you'll notice at the top that
we're we're kind of like calling out
which enemy you currently have targeted
and their level and health and so you
know as you target different characters
you'll be able to get that breakdown the
uh the halo over your head whenever an
enemy is about to an attack it's it's
almost like you have a little bit of a
sixth sense for those things that are
coming
um if you see the Halo it means there's
an incoming attack and if you tap the
triangle button by default then that you
will be able to deflect that attack that
comes in and I love that deflector it
goes off and and like hits things up and
kind of breaks things off walls too but
also uh if you hold the button then it
doesn't just it doesn't just deflect it
also deflects and turns around with a
counter attack Stupify that actually
stuns the enemy and you can use that
even in your Combos and stuff so if
you're focused on a character you know
and you're you're doing your thing and
someone else attacks you you can
actually turn that attack into the
director attack on the person that
you're comboing back into into gameplay
here Andrew's gonna
pretty pretty handily finished these
these other students off here is win
this to do with how fast it is
like a dance
yeah we really felt like the um we
really felt like in the movies there's
almost like a
[Music]
kind of like a there's this element of
kind of like fencing from a very great
distance that's a good call and there
are a lot of uh a lot of things that we
had to do with with our controls and
combat system in order to kind of
capitalize on that idea that's pretty
unique to The Wizarding World well
perhaps you should try that next time
they're the Duelists have already taken
notice of you but after that last round
they'll really have it in for you you'd
better keep practicing if you want a
chance at winning or at least surviving
the next round
I'll let you know when we're ready hope
to see you then
the next round is for all the gobstones
so to speak
and that is more or less gonna wrap it
up for us for now for what we want to
show you character creator tour of
Hogwarts and uh just that that little
taste of combat uh but we we didn't want
to leave you without maybe a little
taste of something that that we're uh we
may show in the future may show next
time uh
you know so leaving the castle
uh going out here
[Music]
more and more owls uh
owl mail there's the owlry again yes all
of the owls
um
but yeah just heading out here again to
show you like from Hogwarts to the world
Beyond Hogwarts and
this is not somewhere where we're going
today but uh we'll we will definitely be
taking you in the future